[Music]
the middle of the 19th century
saw much of america woven together in an
immense
interconnected web all in the name
of electrical telegraph
this cutting-edge technology harnessed
electricity
for wide-scale communication for the
first time
in history telegraph offices all over
america were connected by
fine threads 23 000 miles of electrical
cable
suspended above the ground on lofty
pylons
electricity pulsed between offices
tapping sounders in an intricate code
to be translated into messages by
skilled telegraph officers
[Music]
and on one morning in early september
1859
one such operator noticed something
strange
as he walked to work along the streets
of boston the telegraph cables that
looped above
began to crackle and buzz in a way he'd
never noticed before
as he neared his destination the pylons
that held them aloft
began to sputter and spark even as he
leapt up the stairs and burst into the
telegraph office
a flame of fire jumped from the wires in
the room towards his equipment
setting a pile of papers nearby ablaze
the operator wasting no time tossed the
burning pile through the window and
rushed to disconnect his equipment from
the batteries that powered them
the sparking ceased and he collapsed
into his chair
he still wasn't sure what had caused the
strange surge in electricity
but with the power disconnected from the
equipment the office was safe
for now and yet a short while later
the telegraph began to gently tap
all on its own instinctively
the operator grabbed his writing
equipment and began to decode the
message
it was from the telegraph office in
portland maine
more than 100 miles away their equipment
was disconnected too
with no power to the stations the two
operators communicated back and forth
not through the telegraph lines but
through the very
air itself
so charged was the air with electricity
that the messages were even
clearer than when they traveled through
the wires
no one had witnessed anything like it
before
eventually though the electrification of
the skies subsided a normal service
could resume on the american telegraph
but the messages that arrived after told
of similar strange happenings
all across the country bright
auroras as vivid curtains of light were
spotted as far
south as the caribbean and hawaii making
the night skies
so bright that birds awoke to begin
their dawn chorus
at 1am elsewhere aurora's glowed crimson
reflecting in the ocean turning it
biblical blood red
worldwide people saw these signs and
wondered
if they foretold the end of days
our continued existence on this planet
suggests that it wasn't
in fact the end of days but something
very strange did happen
that day in 1859 something that has not
happened on that magnitude since
and to reveal the source of this
potentially apocalyptic phenomena and
more importantly
why it didn't lead to total worldwide
annihilation will take a journey from
the surface of the sun
to the center of the earth and a trip in
time from earth's earliest moments
to our planets not too distant
future
[Music]
a few hours before the strange
happenings in the boston telegraph
office
on the other side of the atlantic an
english amateur astronomer
trained his telescope on the noonday sun
richard carrington protected his eyes by
projecting the image from the telescope
onto a white screen he then used that
image to track the movement of dark
sunspots across the sun's surface
this study had been going on for many
months but on this day
he saw something different two spots of
bright light
broke out and rapidly grew in intensity
they were so bright that carrington
thought there was a hole in his screen
but as these light patches moved across
the surface with their darker companions
he soon realized they were coming from
the sun
itself
and yet as rapidly as they had appeared
the flashes
began to fade they lasted no more than a
few minutes
and richard carrington just happened to
be in the right place
at the right time to see them
it wasn't too long before the scientific
community began to piece together
carrington's observations
with the global events that followed
giving birth
to the study of space weather
in the process carrington had by chance
witnessed a massive solar flare
an eruption from the sun's surface with
the energy
of 10 billion atom bombs
the flare sent electrified gas and
supercharged
electrons streaming towards the earth at
some large fraction of the speed of
light
these super energetic particles have the
power
to burn and blister skin and damage
our very dna causing long-term
tissue degradation and pervasive cancer
the flare had the potential to [ __ ]
life on earth
not only that but the magnetic effects
of the flare
could set up electric currents in any
conducting material
heating them up and starting
catastrophic fires
electricity cables could sag and snap
any electronic equipment would ionize
and short out destroying circuitry
through direct or indirect action huge
solar flares
had the very real potential to bring
human civilization
as we know it and much of life on earth
to its knees eventually repeated flares
could even erode the planet's protective
ozone layer
and atmosphere leaving the earth dry
and barren exposed to the deep
dark cold of space
but they didn't
instead in 1859 we were treated to eerie
but beautiful light shows
and a few minor incidents on the
telegraph
and that's all thanks to the earth's
protective
magnetosphere this invisible planetary
shield
is created by a self-sustaining magnetic
field
so large that it encompasses the entire
planet this magnetic field acts like
a vast bubble the strong magnetic forces
repel the flare's own magnetic pulses
and deflects the damaging solar wind
around the planet and out into space but
the field withstands the full
force of the sun's bombardment and is
battered into new shapes in the process
sometimes rifts in the planetary shield
open for a short time
channeling the flare's energy into the
earth's atmosphere where it creates
dramatic auroras
as it ionizes the oxygen and nitrogen in
the air
but the magnetosphere is self-healing
and soon
reforms to close these rifts and protect
the planet
once again in fact it has probably
protected the earth from super flares
like the one in 1859
for billions of years and yet
why it's there and how it works is still
something of a mystery
[Music]
civilizations have been aware of the
earth's magnetization
for at least 2 000 years lodestones
naturally magnetic pieces of rock were
known to the chinese in the first
century
and it was discovered that they would
naturally tend to align
north to south
by the 12th century the chinese song
dynasty
were using magnetic compasses for
navigation knowing that wherever they
went
the needle would always point north but
it wasn't until the 17th century
that philosophers and scientists began
to contemplate the causes
behind this universal rule
william gilbert the personal physician
to queen elizabeth the first
spent his spare time studying magnetism
and came to the conclusion
that the entire earth behaved like a
single
gigantic magnet he shaped a lodestone
into a sphere
called the tetorella and used it to
reproduce the angles and tilts of
compass needles
at different points on the surface
studies of the earth's magnetic field
have since advanced
and we now have precise measurements of
the size
strength and variations of this gigantic
field over time and space
and incredibly humans are not alone in
their recognition of earth's magnetic
field
various creatures have even evolved to
sense it and respond to it
just as we might sense and respond to
light or sound or temperature
although scientists are still not sure
of the precise mechanism
birds fish and a range of other animals
have been shown to navigate
with the help of the earth's magnetic
field they can even be thrown off course
by small scale fluctuations caused by
electrical equipment
our knowledge of the interaction between
the planetary magnetosphere
and living things continues to evolve
but a bigger
more fundamental mystery still remains
what exactly causes this planet-saving
planet-sized magnetic field
our planet behaves as if it has
something like a bar magnet
inside of it the magnetic field
concentrates at north and south poles
near the south and north poles of the
planet respectively
but there is no immense bar magnet
lurking inside the earth
geophysicists use the spread of
earthquake waves
to image the inside of the planet the
waves pass
faster through dense materials and
bounce off boundaries to be reflected
back to the surface
so we know the earth's interior is a
series of nested
concentric shells beneath the crust
is the semi-solid rock mantle beneath
that about 3 000 kilometers deep
begins a shell of liquid iron the outer
core
and deeper still the liquid iron is so
compressed that it becomes solid again
forming an inner iron core that's bigger
than the dwarf planet
pluto so no bar magnet
but all of that iron filling up nearly
half of the earth's insides
has magnetic potential and yet not
everything that's iron is magnetic
to make a planet-wide magnetic shield
there must be
something else at work
and in the early 19th century the
self-taught english physicist
michael faraday was beginning to
formulate a theory
on what that something was
faraday was an experimentalist and was
intrigued by the then recent discovery
that electricity movement and magnetism
were intimately related he designed the
first electric motor
which worked by passing an electric
current through a wire
in a magnetic field making it spin
and he reasoned that the same physics
could work in a slightly different way
that by moving an electrical conductor
through a magnetic field
an electric current would be created
this concept led to the development of
the dynamo
that uses spinning magnets and coils of
wire in elegant armatures
to turn mere rotation into electrical
power
this simple concept is at the root of
the electrical generators that produce
almost all our power today
[Music]
but it's not just solid wires and
magnets that can power a dynamo
faraday theorized that the same
principle would work
in liquids too and in 1832 he devised an
ambitious experiment to test his theory
[Music]
from london's waterloo bridge he dipped
two
galvanometers instruments for detecting
electricity
into the flowing waters of the thames
he believed that the motion of the great
river through the earth's magnetic field
would be enough to generate an electric
current within the water
sadly his instruments recorded no
electricity the chemistry of the languid
waters
interfered with any voltages that were
generated but his theory
was sound conductive fluids do
behave electromagnetically
this is good news for the earth's
interior and the generation of its
magnetic field
a hundred years after faraday's
pioneering work german-born physicist
walter el sassa suggested that the
magnetic field
is generated by the dynamo motion of the
planet's
liquid outer core the inner core is a
scorching
6000 degrees celsius while the outer
edge of the outer core
is cooler around 3000 degrees so
heat escapes from the inner core through
the liquid metal
by means of convection rising and
falling plumes of liquid metal
that are sheared sideways by the earth's
own rotation
by extension of the dynamo theory these
deep convective currents elsassa
supposed
were responsible for the planet's
magnetosphere
a self-exciting geodynamo that sustains
and reinforces
a magnetic shield that swaddles
the entire globe in the last 80 years
geophysicists have been able to study
the earth's magnetic field in
ever-increasing detail
and study the fluid motions of this vast
body of liquid metal
but there is still a surprising amount
that we just don't understand
we don't know how the heat which drives
the convection and the currents in the
outer core
is generated of course we have no hope
of probing the unfathomable depths of
the core to find out
and without knowing what creates the
heat we can't know
how it will change in the future or how
it will affect
the magnetic generation as well as this
we don't know the precise motions of the
liquid metals in the core
that are responsible for generating the
magnetic field
and we don't know how or when our
magnetic field was born
it's thought that the solid inner core
plays a crucial role in regulating the
flow
and driving the dynamo but that inner
core probably only formed relatively
recently
in the last billion years or so as the
center of the planet cooled enough for
the iron to solidify
and yet life has persisted for several
billion years and there's evidence of a
magnetic field preserved in rocks
3.5 billion years old
there has been a magnetic shield
protecting our planet from solar super
flares
for far longer than the inner core has
been around so
how did that early early dynamo work
scientists still aren't sure
but they do have a good record of how
the field has changed over time
and what our magnetic future might hold
and it doesn't look good
the magnetic pole in the northern
hemisphere was first pinpointed in 1831
but perhaps surprisingly it wasn't
located at the rotational north pole
but rather in northern canada some 2000
kilometers south
since then the magnetic pole has
wandered across the surface of the
planet
heading north and west today it lies
over the arctic ocean just
500 kilometers off true north
this wandering is the result of the
fluid dynamo
deep within the planet as the currents
shift and shear
so the field it produces wanders
incredibly scientists can even trace
these changes of the magnetic field
back through many million years of
geological time
too lava that erupts at the surface
contains iron-rich minerals
while the rocks are liquid those
minerals feel the tug of the earth's
magnetic field
and align themselves towards the pole
like tiny compasses
then when the rocks cool and solidify
those alignments are frozen in place
by measuring their orientations today we
can reconstruct the movements of the
rock
and the poles over vast spans of our
earth's history
and magnetostratigraphy has helped us
map the movement of continents
across the planet's surface but also
reveals
something remarkable about our magnetic
field
by measuring the alignments of magnetic
materials at the bottom of the atlantic
ocean
a strange pattern emerges stripes
parallel with the mid-atlantic ridge in
which the rock compasses
alternate pointing north and south and
north
and south with the stripes mirrored on
either side of the central ridge
there can be only one explanation for
this curious pattern
the entire magnetic field
switches flip-flopping from north to
south
and back again over periods of millions
of years these so-called magnetic
reversals are seen in rocks
all over the globe and it's now clear
that this magnetic flip-flopping
is a consistent feature of our planetary
shield
they happen at random times sometimes
staying the same for 40 million years
sometimes switching every 200 000 years
but these reversals don't happen
instantaneously
records show that it takes several
thousand years for north and south to
switch
during which time the magnetic bubble
around the planet
would become messy and distorted
with no clear pole to point to compasses
would become useless
auroras which are the result of the
solar wind being channeled along the
field lines
would be seen all over the globe not
just at the poles
but more worryingly with the
magnetosphere so twisted
and diminished it would leave the earth
exposed
to that solar wind putting life on the
planet at risk
in the event of a powerful superflare
although it has never yet happened in
the history of human civilization there
are signs
that things are beginning to change
[Music]
the wanderings of the poll have
accelerated in the last 40 years
and it is now moving across the arctic
ocean at a breakneck speed
of about 55 kilometers a year
at the same time it seems that the
overall geomagnetic intensity
has dropped by 35 percent over the last
two millennia
as the protective magnetosphere bubble
shrinks towards the planet's surface
seeing these changes over our lifetime
reveals just how critical
the magnetic field is to our continuing
existence
if a superflare like the one that raced
towards the earth in 1859 happened again
today
or in the future we would find ourselves
a lot more vulnerable
to its damaging radiation with a weaker
magnetic
field we couldn't say for certain how
well it would withstand
the assault at the same time we have
been putting ever more reliance on our
electrical infrastructure
even placing much of it in orbit around
the planet for the sake of global
connectivity
electronic equipment placed at the edge
of an already shrinking magnetic shield
is especially vulnerable a superflare
could penetrate the planet's defenses
fry the electronics beyond repair and
bring global communications
to its knees intense magnetic pulses
could wipe clean digital records
destroying our history
as well as our present this time
it actually could be the end of days
and so it is a sobering thought that
this invisible shield
created by processes we don't fully
understand
in layers of the earth beyond our reach
might just be the key to our survival up
here
on the delicate surface of earth
next time we will explore what earth was
like three billion years ago
and the incredible story of the planet's
first mass extinction
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth like and subscribe
and leave a comment to tell us what
you'd like to see covered next
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time